let me ask a question i think people are
curious about
when they look at a world-class
leader and thinkers such as yourself as
uh what uh
what books technical fiction
philosophical had a big impact on your
life
and maybe from another perspective what
books would you recommend others read
so my choice the three books right three
books my choice
is um so the one book that really
influenced me a lot when i was building
starting out this company
maybe 10 years ago uh was gb
go to leicester block and um
i like everything about it first of all
it's just beautifully written
and it's so old school and so um
somewhat outdated a little bit but i
think the ideas in it
um about the fact that a few meaningless
components can
come together and create meaning that we
can't even understand
this emerging thing i mean complexity
the whole science of complexity
and uh that beauty intelligence all
interesting things about this world
emerge yeah
and yeah the the ghetto theorem
uh theorems and just thinking about like
what even these form
you know even all these formal systems
something can be created that we can't
quite yet understand
and that from my romantic standpoint
was always just that is why it's
important to
maybe i should try to work on on these
systems and try to build an ai
yes i'm not an engineer yes i don't
really know how it works but i think
that's something comes out of it that's
you know pure poetry and i know a little
bit about that
um something magical comes out of it
that we can't quite put a finger on
that's why that book is it
was was really fundamental for me just
for
i don't even know why it was just all
about this little magic that
uh that happens so that's one that
um probably the most important book for
replica was carl rogers on becoming a
person
um and that's really
and so i think when i think about our
company it's all about there's so many
there's so many little magical things
that happened over the course of
working on it
for instance i mean the most famous chat
bot that we learned about when we
started working on the company was
eliza which was weizenbaum you know the
mit professor that built
build a chatbot that would listen to you
and be a therapist therapist yeah
um and i got really inspired to build
replica when i read
carl rogers so i'm becoming a person and
then i realized that eliza was mocking
carl rogers it was carl rogers back in
the day
but i thought that carl rogers ideas are
they're simple and they're not you know
they're very
very simple but they're they're maybe
the most profound thing i've ever
learned about human beings and that's
the fact that um
before car rogers most therapy was about
seeing what's wrong with people
and trying to fix it or show them what's
wrong with you um
it was all built on the fact that most
people are all people are fundamentally
flawed
we have this uh you know broken psyche
and
this is just a therapist just an
instrument to shed some light on that
and carl rogers was different in a way
that he finally said that well
um it's very important for therapy to
work
is to create this therapeutic
relationship where you believe
fundamentally
an inclination to positive growth that
everyone deep inside wants to
grow positively and change and it's
super important to create this space and
this therapeutic relationship where you
give unconditional positive regard
deep understanding allowing someone else
to be a separate person
full acceptance and you also try to be
as genuine as possible in it
as possible in it and then in his and
then for him that was his own journey of
personal growth
and that was back in the 60s and even
that book that is
you know that's coming from years ago
um there's a mention that even machines
can potentially do that
and i always felt that you know creating
this space is probably the most
uh the biggest gift we can give to each
other and that's why the book was
fundamental for me
personally because i felt i want to be
learning how to do that
in my life and maybe i can scale it with
you know with dci systems
and other people can get access to that
so i think carl rogers
it's a pretty dry and a little bit
boring book but i think they
do let others try to read it i do
i think for just for yourself for
as a human not as a nation as a human
it's it's it is
it is just and for him that was his own
path of his own personal of growing
personally over years
working with people like that and so it
was work and
himself growing helping other people
grow and growing through that and that's
fundamentally what i believe in with
our work helping other people grow
growing ourselves
ourselves um trying to build a company
that's all built on those principles
you know having a good time allowing
some people to work with to grow a
little bit
so these two books and then i would
throw in um
what we have on our in our in our office
when we start a company in russia we put
a
neon sign in our office because we
thought that's that's the recipe for
success
yeah if we do that we're definitely
going to wake up as a
multi-billion dollar company it was um
the ludwig
sign quote the limits of my language the
limits of my world
what was the quote the limits of my
language are the limits of my world
um and i love the tractatus i think it's
just
it's just a beautiful it's a book by
wicked yeah and i would recommend that
too
even although he himself didn't believe
in that by the end of his lifetime and
he debunked his ideas but i think i
remember
once an engineer came in 2012 i think
with 13
a friend of ours who worked with us and
then went went on to work at deepmind
and he gave
talked to us about war 2 vac and i saw
that i'm like
wow that's you know they they wanted to
translate language into
you know some other representation and
that seems like some
you know somehow all of that at some
point i think will come
into this one to this one place
somehow it just all feels like different
people think about similar ideas in
different times from absolutely
different perspectives
and that's why i like these books in the
midst of our lives which is the limit of
our world
and um
we still have that neon sign
it's very hard to work with this red
light in your face
you